well mark it looks as if we might not
have to be waiting too long until that
report is sub is published it could be
hours could be a couple of days uh but
we're getting the sense that it might be
relatively imminent but here at sky news
we can give you a little taster of one
of the things that's gone into that
report i understand that officials who
work in government have been handing
over photographs of what they think of
as parties going on in downing street to
the su-grey report there are images sent
to sue gray of events inside downing
street said to feature boris johnson
according to two sources
they have told me that those images show
both boris johnson and bottles of wine
and people close together evidence i
suspect that will be used both uh in the
report by sue gray and now passed to the
police to form part of the metropolitan
police inquiry until rather covered laws
were broken so this is quite an
interesting development tonight we don't
know whether those uh pictures will be
published as part of the report but we
understand that they're circulating so
brace yourself for images of boris
johnson bottles of wine and people
packed close together
as those images have been handed over to
sue gray
once again delivering yet another blade
to boris johnson